[Music]
kaley is with us in fort worth texas hey
kaley welcome to the ramsay show
hi there how are y'all doing better than
we deserve how can we help
well y'all i'm tired
um
i i have a bachelor's and a master's
degree in biology and i'll tell you all
right now that master's in biology is
the biggest mistake i ever made
i am currently working as a non-profit
uh as a supervisor i've been here for
about three years and i am i really want
to quit my job
um
i'm not enjoying my work anymore i feel
like i've been sidelined i don't feel
appreciated
um but i i'm i'm too afraid to quit i've
got my husband who
he wouldn't be able to take care of all
of us if we were uh if i were to quit
and then i've got a 10 month old baby
boy and so
i'm not really sure where to go through
and go and where to go from here
well let's first deal with the fear
there's nothing for you to be afraid of
because you're not going to quit without
something to walk into okay yeah so
let's just go ahead and let's remove all
of that because you're not going to do
that you have responsibilities and while
you're burned out let's be grateful in
this next season whatever that length of
time is going to be
let's focus on being grateful that's how
you hang on i'm grateful for the check
i'm going to be a good steward of the
time there because i've got to be so
stability is the thing we're grateful
for for 30 to 60 days while you land
something that's it all right so let me
ask you for ken goes on let me ask you
this okay
what do you make
i make 15 hours okay so
you find a job that pays the equivalent
of
30 an hour
doing something that as you look at it
makes you excited and makes you smile
and you take that job
and you accept the position that they
offer you
there is no fear if that happens in
quitting is there
no there would be like a celebration not
fear
right absolutely
confetti
dancing out the whole thing right
right okay ken yeah
so i think you have some ideas
and i think that you're a little bit
concerned about what that looks like to
step into that so let's suspend all
doubt and all fear of stepping in
something else i mean get two degrees
you have a lot of experience and you
have a lot of talent true or false
i true i believe yes you do okay so what
have you thought about that you're just
not sure of how you would get there but
you wonder about it you let your mind
wander to say you know what would that
be like to do this kind of work i think
you have some ideas give me one or two
um
we all i think the main thing is i i
feel like i need to
go outside of what i've put my education
into i've um and that's okay so tell me
the idea it's possible
yeah um
well
i love to be a stay-at-home mom
i love to
do
like
at-home tutoring i love to
i've had a slight inclination about
going into ministry okay why tell me the
why think about the people and the
problem that you want to solve for those
people i want you just tell me that type
of work if i could pay you 30 an hour
today
and you're doing this type of work what
is it don't overthink this it's right
there you've already let it run through
your head about three times while we've
been talking just say it what would you
do because you have to work right now
so what would you do what would you
really enjoy doing if you knew the money
was there say it
i love to write
okay
okay and you love to create you love to
create content to help people so so what
we've got to figure out here is what's
the central problem that you're writing
for or you might be in ministry for
there's a pattern here when you say
ministry when you say tutoring when you
say writing there's a thread that
connects all of those ideas do you
believe that i think so i absolutely
know so
so what is it
what is that writing the ministry the
instructing because that at home
tutoring is a form of coaching or
instructing so there's there's an
equipping side of you you want to help
people
move from a to b is that still true am i
still on the track here with you
yes sir okay so i won't put you on the
spot anymore because i know you're live
and everything but there's a here's what
i want you to hear there is a clear
connection between those three ideas and
it's about a certain group of people and
here's the questions you've got to
answer i'm going to give you the
homework assignment and then i'm going
to give you an assessment that's going
to fast forward the homework here's the
homework i want you to think about those
three ideas that you named and i want
you to think who do i really want to
help well now with the
at-home tutoring or tutoring students
that's a pretty clear answer ministry
there's an answer there and then of
course writing when you write something
it's to write to entertain or it's to
write to inform or it's to write to
equip like the kind of writing that
ramsay personalities do so you always
look at who are the people that i really
want to help what problem do they have
or desire they have that draws me into
that group of people and then the
solutions to that problem or desire
therein lies the ideas for the type of
work the specific job or specific career
path does that make sense
right yeah okay so that's your homework
assignment here's what i know if i
continually i'm asking who are the
people i want help problem i want to
solve solution i want to provide ideas
are going to present themselves and i'm
going to see things that i may not have
seen before
and so what happens next is i get clear
there now i'm looking at what do i want
to do and i choose
okay i want to do this more than i want
to do this it's a season of life i've
got to work i when i decide that i can
go home part time and the husband and i
are on the same page financially then we
can go what's a part-time version of
that same
set of answers and so that's your
progression so right now we want to get
you clear on the types of jobs that you
would be fulfilled in
and then we go what do i need to do to
get qualified all right and in those
three things you have to specifically
look into it what do i need to do learn
how much is that going to cost how long
will that take
and now we can see here's a path forward
and we're not so overwhelmed
now if you once you identify all of that
then that's going to take you all the
way through the process to
actually identify jobs that do those
things and then go get one of those jobs
and then quit and it'll be more fifteen
dollars an hour no question and you know
you just got you've worked through the
process so you don't land
back in something else that's
frustrating
and quote burned out and all that kind
of a thing
um and so
yeah hang on kelly's going to pick up
we're going to give you a copy of ken's
um assessment process and it's a 30
process to take the test but we're
giving it to you
and you can take this assessment you
take it just a few minutes and it'll
give you a real clear the takeaways from
that assessment can are really important
yeah what happens is you get a full
report on what you do best people talk
about skills here and then the type of
work you love and then what motivates
you in other words the results that when
your work produces this result at ramsey
solutions all of us everybody in the
building our work produces
hope transformational content that
people can use to practically change
their life and so when you get that
report then we put it in a purpose
statement and what we love about the
purpose statement dave is what we're
hearing from people that use the
assessment is that it becomes a 30 000
foot view think of in an airplane i'm
looking down
and i can see multiple specific jobs and
those descriptions and i look and i say
do they match up with my purpose
statement and that gives us confidence
to say okay i know i can do this now the
assessment also even throws out some
possible it actually gives you
possibilities we hold this very loosely
because it's impossible assignments
anybody that tells you that they can
predict what career you should do with
an assessment is lying to you
they can cause you to predict it they
can allow you to look and we give you
suggestions and so it's a wonderful tool
let's also kelly give her the book from
paycheck to purpose because this is the
companion if you will uh once you know
the mountaintop you want to scale this
will help you guide you up the mountain
but i will tell you dave there's one
other suggestion here when i hear that
somebody's really burned out there's a
lot of factors going on
and if we know we don't want to stay
there but we're just looking for a
bridge
you know you can go get a better paying
job that is temporary day job meaning
i'm not invested in it but it's gonna
pay me 25 30 bucks an hour as a bridge
while i'm
seeking the ultimate path yeah that's a
suggestion you can go do that i probably
would give 30 days a job hunter 45 days
a job
for the main position first sure but if
that doesn't work you know like by the
end of the summer by september i'll just
take a 25 an hour job at target yeah
because that's stinking what they're
paying the answer
so uh get you 40 hours and how you feed
your family while you land in the big
job again